الآن الساعة 11 صباحًا بقليل في اليونان
حيث تبحث أطقم العمل عن ناجين
بعد حطام قطار مروّع حتى الآن
تأكد مقتل أكثر من 36 شخصًا
بعد اصطدام قطار ركاب
بقطار شحن بالقرب من مدينة
لاريسا ، علمنا منذ لحظات أنهم
كانوا  يبدو أنه يسافر على نفس
المسار لفترة طويلة وكذلك
تحاول السلطات التعرف على
الضحايا sinenzolini jokos تتبع هذا
مباشر لنا من Dubai Eleni أولاً وقبل
كل شيء
ماذا نعرف عما حدث هنا
أعني أنه من الواضح جدًا من
الصور كيف  سيء إنه أمر
سيء ولديك قطار بضائع
يسافر من ثيسالونيكي
وقطار الركاب الذي يسافر من
أثينا متجهًا نحو الاصطدام ، أول
عربتين تلتقطان ضوءًا ويمكنك
رؤية المعدن المدمر المشوه الذي
لديك رافعات ولديك معدن  قطع
الآلات لمحاولة قطع هاتين
العربات الأولى وهذا هو الخوف
من أن المزيد من الناس محاصرون وأن
عدد القتلى يرتفع الآن إلى 38
أم عندما كنت على الهواء آخر مرة كان 36
لديك 66 شخصًا أصيبوا
سبعة من  الذين هم حاليًا في حالة مكثفة